in a lobby of financial peace plaza
daniel and kimberly are with us hey guys
how are you
we're doing awesome yeah welcome welcome
where are you from
we're from Laurel Maryland Oh fine well
welcome good to have you thanks for
coming to hang out with us then so what
about a five hour drive six hour drive
me so here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off seventy six
thousand seven hundred fifty four
dollars I love it and how long did that
take about twenty eight months yeah
twenty-eight months making what kind of
money we started out making about fifty
six thousand in the last year now we're
making about seventy okay excellent
so what happened to cause that increase
in pay we got married no I got I
recently got a promotion they now work
in the county was working at a private
school before and so I was able to make
a little bit more money yeah that's your
teacher yeah what do you guys teach I
teach fifth grade
um and I'm teaching Bible and history
okay and I teach second grade math Oh
fun good for you guys yeah so
seventy-seven thousand dollars in debt
was what what kind of debt Sallie Mae we
owed this girl named Sallie need to be
booted to the curb the whole thing was
student loans whole thing no notice now
that worked that way yeah so how long
ago did you get married
Oh three years ago we just celebrate our
third-year anniversary okay so you get
married and you look up and say okay
first order of business pretty quick
after getting married 28 months ago 36
you got married and then you say six
months after that we're gonna start on
this debt huh well actually didn't start
out like that we had no budget
whatsoever when we first got married and
then my father he's a pastor they were
having the financial peace classes who
said that we should take it and I'm
gonna do anything my father in law says
so he's like do this I'm like yes sir
I'm doing it so we did son-in-law
that's fine so you went to a Financial
Peace University yes and you went in
there because some I told you you should
but then all of a sudden what happened
our mind is blown so we had lots of
people in the class with us and I think
we were one of the younger ones and they
were like if you don't take advantage of
the opportunity you have before you
you're crazy
and I think that really just helped us
understand like if we just go ahead and
just tackle this debt now it's the only
debt we have what that could do to our
future and how that kind of makes that
stamp on our legacy yeah that's the
beauty of the Financial Peace University
class the whole people absolutely
encourage young people to do it I mean
it's like yeah that's good I like it
that's fine what was the hardest thing
you did in the last twenty eight months
to get out of debt I think using the two
letter word no just friends family
always want us to come visit all the way
out in Colorado and everywhere else and
we just had to tell them no and they
understood our situation but you know
people still always ask hey you coming
out this weekend are you going here you
go in there and we're like you know just
married and so they want to go out or
you know you know go out with the girls
or whatever and we have to consistently
say no we can't do that because we know
we're paying off debt not anymore not
anymore yeah that's cool so did people
make fun of you understand oh yeah
they're like oh why don't you just keep
the debt like it's not a big deal and
I'm like no and everybody's got it
everybody's doing it and I just got a
job like I said I just got into the
public school arena and so being the new
person on site everyone's like let's go
out to lunch you know there's a baby
shower let's buy this for them and I'm
like I can't spend all this money like I
have a goal and that was really hard for
them to understand my circumstance but
it is what it is
Wow well good for you guys
congratulations I'm proud of you how's
it feel phenomenal amazing I had a
burden I haven't had a clothing budget
in a year and a half we completely
stripped everything like no clothing
budget like I didn't have and that was
like the biggest thing I was like I
can't get any more clothes I do what I
have
and we really we got extra jobs we
hadn't did so many extra jobs what was
the worst actor job worst Wow
well let's see we did summer school
summer camp tutoring catering delivered
pizzas dog-sitting maintenance
babysitting pretty much anything that
was extra at work that making us extra
money we did it what was the thing that
paid the best Oh
when you say man that one that one is
sweet I'm gonna do that more I think the
catering was a good one for him yeah
yeah that a lot of hours and you got a
good amount of money you're working for
a caterer are you dedicating working for
Kate okay yeah all right cool so we're
just when they were in someone's home or
office doing a deal you were there
helping to wait and do all that wreck
okay correct good very cool good for you
it's amazing jobs are there when you
look for him they are yeah
how did you find all of those jobs we
had some people um yeah word of mouth we
had some people um who might be working
the catering so we went and talked to
them my brother was working delivering
the pieces so I talked to him so just
talking to people networking I'm willing
to do whatever yeah nothing was worse
like babysitting well please I'll do it
everybody's a lot everything yeah that
is so cool well that's how you get out
of debt it's also how you want it life
work is a good thing man yes I'm telling
you you guys are impressive very good to
talk to you thank you for making the
trip all the way from Maryland yeah
alright it's Daniel and Kimberly seventy
seven thousand dollars paid off in
twenty eight months making fifty six now
seventy but about twenty six extra jobs
involved I love it count it down let's
hear a great debt free scream here we go
three two one
I love it
way to go YouTube that is so well done
absolutely fabulous I love it oh man